Deep frying,
a Turkey can oftentimes be incredibly dangerous.
So why don't we try a different cooking method?
Let's send our Turkey up into space and have it
come to earth while moving at the speed of light.
Do you think this would be any safer?
How fast is the speed of light?
Could a Turkey moving this fast damage the earth
and what would happen once it reaches our atmosphere?
This is what if, and here's what would happen.
If a Turkey hit the earth at the speed of light,
the speed of light is nearly 300,000 kilometers per second.
If an object we're going this fast,
it could circle the earth seven and a half times in just a single
second.
So what would happen if we made a Turkey move this fast
and then hurled it toward our planet
before we go any further,
we should let you know that it's impossible for an object to move at the speed
of light that's because the faster an object moves,
the more it's mass increases and it's length contracts.
In other words, when our Turkey is moving at the speed of light,
it would have an infinite mass and a length of zero,
which is impossible, but we won't let our fun stuff there.
Instead, we're going to have our Turkey move at 99.99%.
The speed of life, suck on that Einstein.
And now moving at this speed in space,
the Turkey is coming from earth,
but before it even hits our planet,
we've noticed some of the effects long before it impacts
as the Turkey is moving through Earth's atmosphere.
It would start to slam into atmospheric particles.
Since it's moving at such a high speed,
the Turkey would begin to get ripped apart.
If you wanted to look up in the sky,
you'd see bright explosions in our atmosphere,
but the volume of the explosions would probably make you instinctively
run for cover and hide. This might not.
You sound all that terrible,
but it would still cause massive destruction on earth surface,
the closest modern equivalent to something like this would be the
Chelyabinsk meteor in 2013,
that meteor exploded at a height of 23.3 kilometers.
And when that happened,
it resulted in 1000 people getting injured and huge amounts
of property damage. Our Turkey.
Moving at the speed of light would be equal to 40,000 of those meteors
hitting earth. And these explosions wouldn't happen all at once,
but sporadically,
as it moves through the atmosphere as they happen there,
shockwaves would cause buildings and windows to be completely destroyed.
And if this were to happen,
it would be the earth best case scenario.
That's because this Turkey hasn't even hit the planet yet,
but if it did come right for us,
then the results would be even worse
due to all the energy behind it.
If the Turkey hit New York city at 99.9,
9% of the speed of light,
it would be like dropping 400 nuclear bombs.
This would completely destroy the city,
not dimension parts of the planet itself.
The impact from this massive explosion could destroy the Earth's
crust causing magma to spew up and fill the
streets.
Massive fires would start and millions of people would die,
but ground zero wouldn't be the only place heavily affected
an impact earth.
Like this could cause earthquakes and fires all across North
America.
An entire half of the world would be completely destroyed just from a
harmless Turkey.
So the speed of light can be pretty dangerous.
But what might happen if you rode your bike at this speed?
Well, we'll leave that story for another.
What if cool. Yeah. And happy Thanksgiving.